this is an incredible honor that i never
could have imagined and there are so
many people to thank first and foremost
my beekeepers
clay dan alex cherlene and so many
others who didn't make it in the final
film but who were so generous with their
time and with their stories it really is
something special to be trusted with the
details of someone's life and so i i
really can't thank them enough for the
opportunity and i also have to thank my
amazing advisor jennifer redfern my
editing coach mike shen technical
advisor chris o'day and my classmates
and my colleagues who helped
you know guide me through this process
and gave me so much feedback and there
were certainly tough times and tears and
um it was all worth it to make this
story sing and um i have to thank my
composer merritt myers who really his
his music added life and depth to this
film in ways that i couldn't have given
him direction for he just really he took
the story and he ran with it and made it
something special um
and i also i my family i wouldn't be
here without them my family and my
husband michael
they supported me endlessly made sure i
was eating enough and sleeping enough
throughout this process and it
it wouldn't have been possible without
them this is
you know
amazing thank you to everyone that i've
named and everyone i haven't it's it's
truly an honor